well that's it another CES is coming on
now this year the mood was a little more
subdued there were somewhat fewer people
attending this year but this is still
North America's largest electronics
trade show it's still gigantic and there
were still a lot of cool products one of
the biggest stars of the show was the
palm pre a new smartphone from palm and
it looks really cool it's got a touch
screen and a slide-out QWERTY keyboard
and it has a really innovative looking
new operating system with a very elegant
interface I can't wait to get my hands
on one when it becomes available later
this year palm hasn't said exactly when
or how much it will cost also attracting
a lot of attention from people at the
show is a new sony vaio notebook which
is extremely small it's got an 8 inch
wide format screen very elegant running
Windows Vista and just looks great so
lots of people were talking about that
at the show one of the biggest trends we
saw at CES this year is budget
electronics now manufacturers weren't
exactly trumpeting this but every single
one that we talked to had a line of
economy minded models whether those were
stereo receivers or TVs or in the case
of one of the hottest product categories
right now netbooks every manufacturer is
offering something that's cheap and
they're obviously thinking about the
economic times and trying to get
products out there that people will
still be willing to buy the economy is
definitely on many people's minds but
frankly there's still a lot of optimism
here at CES and of course it does take a
while for the electronics industry to
catch up to the economic realities so
next year it's possible that CES will be
even smaller it's also possible that
manufacturers will come out with even
more recession minded gadgets like who
knows electronic hobo stoves or
something but for now there's still lots
of glitz there's still lots of great
products and with the palm pre coming
out this year it should still be a great
year for gadgets